this is from will this just says is it
garbage to throw m m's in the toll if
you don't have coins
[Applause]
you treat yourself buddy it's on me
one of those is a peanut all right
wash down your sandwich with and lunch
holy [ __ ] heaven oh man
oh that's [ __ ] beautiful
red bank all right okay
okay
where's brian m
yeah this isn't going to end well
[Laughter]
what do you do for a living
oh god
[Applause]
red bank you're like a [ __ ] dirt ball
onion i like this this is like the
world's worst job fair
this is crazy if you put in a regular
fence i'm not qualified for that
i'm only on dogs god damn it
you got a squirrel or a possum i can
make you a cage
and i can't do people fences
i don't have my degree yet
you ever test out the dog fence put the
collar on yourself and get close to
he
it
[Laughter]
hey you got to get those tick tock
numbers up somehow huh
we used to put it around our neck and go
in front of the tv and zaps you in front
of the tv
try the refrigerator next time
[Laughter]
that's what i'm here for
i love you big guy
oh this one's cuckoo bananas dude
all right let's just get to brian's
this is about the ocean
is that you or your brother's legs
ever sit in the ocean waist deep in a
hefty bag because you have two broken
legs from your dad running you over in
the driveway weeks before
how bad do you need to go to the beach
the [ __ ] stay at home man
did he break both of your legs
god damn what kind of car i don't think
this was a mercedes
the non-convertible or convertible
no convertible chrysler sebring
i think they made like four of those
and everyone had a doughnut on it
holy [ __ ]
and what beach was this
of course it was
[Applause]
let's go baby these are my people
yeah i didn't think it was [ __ ]
martha's vineyard so i'll tell you that
yeah this wasn't a stone harbor crowd i
picked up on
how old were you when this happened 32
five five
your dad ran over you when you were five
years old damn you must have been a bad
kid oh [ __ ] dude
holy [ __ ]
get over here little [ __ ]
was it a scented trash bag
this cast itches but this lemony smell
is fantastic that lavender keeps the
sharks away i'll tell you that
all right clap it up for these two
brothers
that was [ __ ] all right
is it garbage oh sorry where's robert f
yeah
what's up dude how are you front row
baby look at you huh
is it garbage if your parents got
together because your mom lived next
door to your dad and his first family
and she babysat my half brothers holy
[ __ ] p.s i was for sure born out of
wedlock
[Applause]
give yourselves a round of applause red
bank gay [ __ ] love you